okay let's bring in Florida Republican
senator Marco Rubio Vice chairman of the
intelligence committee and a member of
the Foreign Relations Committee he
endorsed former president Trump last
month Senator Rubio good to have you
with us thank you very much thanks Mar
so I guess let's start there is this a a
good bill and is it going to fix the
problem to your satisfaction and are you
supporting it well first of all we don't
know what the bill is it's not out yet
so I can't give you my opinion on a bill
that isn't written no one's read and not
just me no one's seen it yet that
doesn't mean it's bad or good I just I
don't know what it is but let me I will
tell you this Joe Biden does not need a
bill if he wants to enforce the Border
this border Crisis began when he took
office because on his first day in
office he wiped out all the Trump
proposals people that are coming to this
country illegally they don't know what
our immigration laws are they don't know
the details of uh Asylum laws what they
know is this if you come to the border
and you turn yourself in they will
process you and they will release you
and they will and you are going to
probably get to stay in this country for
the rest of your life that's what they
know because that's what other people
have done and and that's what's causing
more people to come and the only thing
that will stop this is to change that
for people to know if you're here
illegally you will not be allowed in if
you get in you will be detained and you
will be held until your hearing and if
the hearing is 5 years from now then
you'll be detained for 5 years and until
we get back to that this crisis will
continue no matter what law we pass yeah
I I think you're absolutely right I I
mean if all of these people flooding to
the Border learn that they're going to
be held in a detention center for 90
days and that the likelihood that they
will be sent back back after all of that
is very very high if they don't meet the
Asylum Bard border uh you know if they
don't meet the Asylum requirements I
should say excuse me um what kind of
impact would just that have on their
thinking about coming to this country
well a lot less people would come look
I'm not speculating about this okay I
live in Miami I interact with people
that have come illegally that have sent
money via cashap and venmo and whatever
to people to traffic their relatives
here and they all tell you they
basically say we we know if you can get
to the border and you get in they're
going to release you you have an 85 90%
chance which is a very high probability
of being released into the country
that's why they are coming because Biden
has made that very clear and those are
policy choices those are choices that he
made about who to detain who not to
detain who to release how to release
them and what to give them when you
release them so if he's not willing to
do that that's already within his power
now he's not going to do anything on the
boorder no matter what law we passed
well he he said uh last week that if
that bill were the law today I would
shut down the border right now said Joe
Biden but let's remind people what he
said on September 12th in the middle of
the presidential debate when he was
running to be president watch this I
would in fact make sure that there is we
immediately surge to the Border all
those people are seeking Asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
we're a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing oppression you should
come so Senator as we understand it this
bill you're going to get to read it in
the next 24 to 48 hours a is that your
understanding and B how you know how do
you think that this is going to be
something that you're going to be able
to get behind once you read it I'm sure
you've heard as many of the elements
that are in it as you can and are we
going to get relief on this issue
Democrats Republicans Americans well
again I don't know what's in the bill it
hasn't been described to us in detail so
all Reserve judgment but I'm going to
tell you right now I don't believe that
a president that right now had went all
the way to the Supreme Court to fight
against border security okay to fight
against Texas he should be thanking
Texas that that president is somehow
going to enforce a stricter law on the
border he doesn't want to do this he
won't do it no matter what law we
pass Senator Rubio thank you very much
uh we look forward to speaking with you
obviously there's a lot more to talk
about we've got Ukraine in that bill
Israel in that bill uh and you are an
expert on foreign policy so I hope we'll
get to speak with you soon thank you
very much sir thank you hey everyone I'm
Emily compano catch me and my co-hosts
Harris vulner and Kaye mechan on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights